what's the use of putting your money
into a savings account if it's going to
end up being a losing investment the
European Central Bank has been trying to
battle its way through the block
sovereign debt crisis over the past few
years with cheaper money but at the
expense of ordinary depositors I'm been
for zulan this is made in Germany and
here are some of the topics will be
looking at today hard-won savings eaten
away by inflation what's happening to
your bank account big a bigger leap hair
a global machinery giant shoveling
billions of euros in annual sales and
borrowing or sharing instead of buying
and you internet platform called why own
it we start the show off with a man who
made his fortune before hitting 40 but
more amazing is what he's doing with the
money no there are no racing cars
involved or yachts or private jets this
German multi-millionaire yarn Henrik
buettner has bought an entire village on
the Baltic Sea and he's turning it into
a playground for the rich and famous the
rundown village of Ison house is
undergoing a transformation with big
plans for the future here's the man and
a little look into his childhood
yeah that's it because here's the place
back then there was no boardwalk I built
it mine's got fat Ned's he had made him
talk about a beach doesn't change that
much and of course of one's life watch
that step
dumpin Canyon Univision to happen as a
child I was once playing in the dunes
and stepped on a nasty piece of broken
glass I spent about a week in the
hospital because of that beer bottle
shard easy glass yeah laughing but
otherwise all my memories of this Beach
are positive don't do this done and now
yawn Hanley patna has returned to
schleswig-holstein straight from
California he wants to turn the beach
and the nearby abandoned village into a
luxury hotel complex called Palace
estate of ison house dear Tyga boy too
tight a fund in mind these three
buildings we can only see two of them
make up the spa the forest thermal
springs this is the historic coach house
coach novice doesn't it man that's the
new building guns in the boy too complex
huh and with this tunnel we've connected
the entire new building complex to the
manor all kind of as you can see off
gobbet was it's not an easy task the
dough legs had to be supported from
below so that when the tunnel was dug
the building's wouldn't tilt most of his
guard Nevadan
buettner has been a builder for eight
years now how about Xavier
he used to be an internet entrepreneur
now he commutes between Hamburg and the
United States he and his architect visit
the construction site once a week fitna
gested around the world for years now he
wants to bring all his impressions and
experience back home he's already
invested fifty million euros in this
oldest age it was born between us Wow is
he not report for other stuff but now
was a manager with a battles month
publishing company and made a fortune
when it sold off AOL Europe almost 10
years ago what kinda is need to remind
us home if you've earned a little
fortune it doesn't mean you can just
retire at forty and saith and I'm just
gonna sit by my pool and drink champagne
that doesn't make sense you've got to do
something and then came the big surprise
the opportunity to buy an historic
village in a highly industrialized
country directly on the Baltic Sea and
here i can shape and plan everything
just the way I like it not detect an
Aussie to Collinwood little dark and
there's nothing around it to disturb me
mr. mobile miss as if as make it will be
stood the project is expected to cost
almost 17 million euros at some point
the investment has to pay for itself a
stolid see if it'll take 10 to 14 years
that's my estimate and the good thing is
that it's all invested in a way that it
doesn't have to recoup the money
immediately there are loans to be paid
off as well as interest a lot of the
money is my own habitat and some comes
from other investors what's that it
seemed all I can copy time but they
don't expect the money be paid back
right away the Afghan on board d it's
mr. evapn dicey the skate is always
afford with its open Cybercom britnie is
gradually revamping the old village it
has a total of forty houses many of
which will be turned into vacation
apartments his hotel director shows us
the model sweet
the card reader is here to the left
under the land its contact free you just
have to hold the card within two
centimeters of it and it unlocks the
door it opens at a touch okay a suite
with four rooms including a kitchen and
a children's room costs 600 euros a
night seven restaurants are planned and
one is already open the boathouse
restaurant is right down on the beach
where burtner played as a child Lanyon
had as of ya cryin when i was a child i
collected jellyfish and shells right
there my parents used to drive in and
park over there sugeng ukunda mandava
thea back then it wasn't a car-free
nature preserve you could drive in and
park under trees and walk to the beach
would of it there's a snack bar with
french fries and hot dogs and then this
is where I played as a child and when my
kids were small they did the same next
time on DEATH laga nomas yawn hey Naresh
buettner envisions hotel guests already
strolling on the beach this year while
he will continue to commute between the
Baltic and the Pacific and we'll just
have to wait to see if that huge
investment does pay off one day the more
money you have the more problems it must
be hard to sleep at night not knowing
what to do with it all but for those who
haven't struck it rich what's the best
thing to do with whatever is left over
from the money you're making right now
because with historically low interest
rates in some parts of the world and
high inflation what's the use of putting
that cash into a savings account that's
just going to a road away what is it
bank asks the primary school teacher you
can put 50 years into it every month
flesh oh oh and then they add something
to it yeah that's called interest you
get interest
since interest for those who save their
money in Germany even children know that
and to support that cause the project
school piggy bank was launched to teach
primary school peoples that saved money
increases I'm saving my money and when
I'm about 18 i can buy a house and a car
and if there's something left over i
could put it into my accounts but what
if people's savings are no longer secure
banks are currently paying very low
interest it's frustrating for savers
because things have turned upside down
for savings accounts accounts aren't
growing but shrinking day by day a
creeping expropriation
the reason is that since 2010 the
inflation rate is higher than the
interest on a fixed deposit account at
the moment savers receive only 0.9
percent interest while prices are rising
at about 1.5 percentage can you imagine
that the money is melting away that
would make me angry but bank customers
aren't getting angry yet behavioral
economist ma teen kasia says that's
because of the inertia of the mass
germans traditionally big savers are
especially affected bc kadesh nozzles
comes in a major fraction of government
spending goes to interest payments low
interest rates make serving debt cheaper
so the state can spend on other things
savers benefit from some of those things
but it's clear low interest rates are
always bad for people who have
substantial savings and good for states
that are in debt one sec would finish
talking dish Republican politicians are
trying to control the crisis at the
expense of savers but Mario Draghi in
the European Central Bank plan to
maintain the course of low prime
interest rates that means the financial
industry has access to the cheapest
money in history
the european central bank wants to
stimulate the economy by increasing the
bank's liquid assets but where does the
money go what are the banks say love the
sched other where is the money girl well
in part the banks don't need the money
from the European Central Bank they can
refinance themselves with their deposits
so you can believe me the banks aren't
happy at all about this cheap money and
especially not about the great volume of
money that is currently circulating
who's really upset are the people with
bank accounts on Cyprus their accounts
are being used to rescue decrepit banks
in the euro sabres all over Europe are
getting nervous pesaran defender is not
truly it's difficult for me to advise
the children to save a lot of money if
it means later at 18 they'll have less
than they actually saved it's a problem
for me so should the children save or
spend all their money a difficult
question maybe the children should wait
to save until the turbulence of the euro
subsides joining us now is the director
of the Hamburg Institute of
International Economics Thomas stop on
what's your advice to kids put the money
in the piggy bank or spend it on toys I
did this is a very difficult question
because we cannot learn from the past it
is not a good advice to look what we
have done when we were young to learn
what they now should do definitely they
have probably to save even more than we
had because they do not count on the
interest rate so they have to really do
it on their own for all their purposes
wishes needs for the future and so I
think this is a very tough situation and
yet they have probably to search for
alternatives to the saving accounts one
alternative for adults at least is
insurance policies they usually pay what
two and a half percent but how long can
the insurers keep that up that's a very
good question because in time in a
period of so low interest rates
very demanding promise they did to
really say that we get all this
expectation expected returns so they
have also to search for other
alternatives and probably they have to
take more risks by investing this money
for a longer period briefly what are
some of the alternatives probably
infrastructure what is a quite quite a
new phenomena for long-term investments
but also raw materials and also of
course shares because they may probably
give you the best expectations for the
future back to the topic of easy money
banks having it easy with the central
bank with the european central bank
customers haven't had it easy though
when they go into miners with their bank
accounts that means what eleven percent
that they have to pay isn't that an
obscene difference in a way yes but on
the other hand the banks they have to
search for liquidity and everybody also
is keeping the liquidity because they do
not trust each other so somehow the
transmission channels are damaged and so
i think it is not fair just to blame the
banks of course also the states they
profit because the debt burden for the
public coffers is quite lowering mr.
scalper will return to you in a moment
first of all the story we flanked
earlier about borrowing or sharing as
opposed to buying share economy was the
big topic at this year's see bit trade
fair the world's most important event
for the digital economy the term
describes a trend in society from owning
to sharing anything from knowledge
resources experience to everyday items
like cars and clothing it's the internet
that makes it all so easy but no matter
how good the swap the question still
remains do I look fat in this
this doesn't look too posh does it does
it make me look fat this thing what it
makes me look fat they said they girls
okay okay clothing swap parties like
this one in F would are all the rage you
clean out your closet and bring along
whatever no longer suits you and swap it
it's a great way to spruce up a wardrobe
and it's free and it's like tis an
actress she's here to swap and brought
her daughter's along my guide says I
mean I tried to bring a lot and take a
little and in doing so empty out my
closet her daughter Clara is busy trying
on clothes not how she found anything
she likes yes a lot of things like this
jacket the scarf another jacket and
sweater in padova Netherland be a buck
holds the swap parties in her yoga
studio she sees it as a good way to
reduce consumption and waste Findus
thought you had Shirin Vytas it's nice
because it's also an event people chat
while they swap and it's fun it's like
shopping without spending money swapping
and sharing instead of shopping it's an
idea that's taking off nearly a quarter
of all Germans take advantage of
services like car sharing or online
swapping platforms these computer
programmers in Hamburg are hoping to
cash in on the trend Philip lukla
founded the company why own it members
uses a poor homepage to borrow whatever
they need everything from a drill to a
DVD and it's free CDs methought that's
why I'm yeah I got the idea about a year
ago I thought it would be cool to see
what my friend zone what they like and
need
it's a way to buy less and see my
friends more often i'm becoming a fine
to assess dezeen as a deep the products
are usually just an excuse to get in
touch with people again contact with him
ineligible but i haven't bought anything
but food this year it's awesome smitten
so far the company hasn't earned any
money yet gluck la has financed his
startup company with help from six
private investors he sees it as a way to
change consumption habits and promote
sustainability in missing in each
other's we don't need to buy everything
we see in advertisements for example
when a media company says we need to buy
their dvds blackity it does include all
we really want to do is watch it once
and have that experience I'm a decision
aslam I'm IDs in Finn's a coil he
already has ten thousand registered
members his dream is to achieve a
critical mass so that no one has to buy
anything they don't need to earn money
he includes advertising on his site back
in a food spirits are high the bargain
hunters are happy and they've had a
great afternoon getting together with
friends but will it really cut down on
the amount of shopping they do Cal Viet
watsonville I will continue to buy
things but it's a good mix when I go
shopping i buy exactly what I need as if
I scan all about the village calif with
us and but here there are great finds
things that i can combine and be really
creative spawn dr. Claire tp2 done I'm
communion service via one person's trash
is another person's treasure swapping
instead of buying it's an idea that's
taken off so borrowing instead of buying
what do you think of this model I think
this is a perfect fit for demand and
supply somehow and it is nothing new by
the way we always had second-hand shops
to somehow do barter exchange so firstly
it helps to bring together the wishes
from both sides of the market so I think
this is a perfect fit and it actually
does not harm
the consumer industry because the money
you are going to save you will just give
out for other things but is this still
is it a niche market or is it something
that's really catching on yeah it's
still a niche market for for the
quantities and the volumes they are
still small even if they grow fast in
the last couple of years but still
compared to the total sales they are
just a minor tiny fraction what about
the losses though for specific companies
like car makers say I wouldn't say that
they really are going to lose they will
probably from sector to sector or from
car type to another car type they will
have changes in the demand but as I've
said before the money they are going to
safe they will probably spend to buy
more expensive cars later on so i think
all over all this is also a beneficial
to the car industry because it helps to
bring together supply and demand and is
it a trend elsewhere yes of course we
know it from all the markets and
especially from the markets for software
and hardware in the computer sector that
you are going to share these facilities
and I also think there it is a kind of
reaction to the technology technology
and it is a kind of a global market I'll
that will arise and enter train not just
here in Germany no definitely not okay
thank you very much mr. Sproul power for
your analysis well I did my fair share
of sharing as a kid I was second in line
that meant a whole lot of hand-me-downs
but if the shoe fits why not now
question of the week would you consider
bartering instead of buying let us know
by visiting our website d w dot de /
english / made in germany now last week
we wanted to know if you've already put
your money somewhere safe Christina
bokmål wrote in for the Philippines to
say she's never been in a position to
have to worry about where to put large
lump sums of money or whether to invest
it in obscure island safe havens but
even if she could afford such a hobby
she wouldn't be interested Christina
says honesty is always the best policy
now half a million visitors are
currently
sending on Munich for the world's
largest trade fair for construction
machinery Ballmer if you're into
autopilot filled Rovers walking mobile
excavators or hybrid energy wind towers
constructed with revolving tower cranes
then this is for you the biggest
exhibitor of the show is the German firm
leap hair which also boasts some of the
biggest equipment on offer
centimeter 4 centimeter the multi-ton
vako is moved into position but good
isn't good enough on the fairgrounds for
site manager too much Ava he is on hand
to make sure everything is on the up and
up as a Connecticut we have to work link
for link thank you there's a track on
the left and right each of them has a
logo this we have to make sure their
upright and level leappad doesn't leave
anything to chance they've been working
for years on their presentation at the
bow ma the world's largest fear for
construction machinery in Munich some
Lightning get it this one's designed for
lining it weighs 400 tons and can assume
different roles in the quarry or be used
in different types of mines gold mines
diamond mines and copper mines for
example hopeful meeting lipa has rolled
out 67 of their construction vehicles
including the largest highest payload
capacity haul truck in the world the T
282 its wheels alone are 4 meters in
diameter with machines this big even
full-grown men let out their inner child
Nick Bellamy has 35 specialized driver's
licenses for construction vehicles he
will demonstrate the T 282 tipping
function it has to give up ok it takes
around 12 seconds for the bed to raised
into position when it's under a full
load on and then about 8 seconds to
lower it on the cover
bubble-hockey go think it's umm Kulthum
up you can buy this one starting at a
million dollars Lola has over twenty
eight hundred horsepower and can
transport 200 tons well not that its own
we make a smaller version in care store
or the TV in kerkhoff leap has kicked
off factory 100 kilometers west of
munich leaf has smaller construction
vehicles are being put through their
paces the smaller version of the t 282
features a special joint between the
driver's compartment and the truck bed
Matthias hartzog is an engineer and
production leader and finished off
sometimes he likes to take leap as
vehicles for a test drive now who does
fancy hit bus unless the crimes a bit
differently because of the joint it's
not like a normal vehicle we have to get
used to it and of course the 370
horsepower 160 shah pahlavi
each construction vehicle also needs a
hydraulic system hydraulic bar arms
provide the power for gripper arms and
truck beds in cash off they need around
40,000 per year yeah why not yeah of
course this is a dream job from any man
construction vehicles fascinate lots of
boys from an early age is fascinating to
see how you can move tons of material as
if they were light as a feather again
it's isolated one that I spill
illustrating cutting the gripper arm was
custom made most of bleep as vehicles
are tailored to meet each customer's
demands and that requires teamwork I
sign it balling we have to double check
that it was properly mounted and that
the hoses are right those are some of
the practical problems our workers deal
with daily we're not a typical assembly
line backhoe manufacturer we make each
piece individually that's our spring
ball move on we're sending four of these
to the bomber this backhoe will also be
making an appearance at the bow matrade
fair the leap hand 918 with a price tag
of two hundred thousand euros it's a big
seller in Europe but lipa has its sights
set on new markets for its vehicles it's
hoping the bow mo will open the door to
new customers in the developing world
and while the world keeps developing and
leap air keeps doing its digging I'm
going to leave you to keep doing
whatever you do I'll be back soon though
with another edition of made in Germany
see you then
you